[Musique]
comm réd
jb de politique je vais car durieux
elle est disponible if you wanna have
posted on tuesday to what the guardian
légumes secs tout seul manière dont les
seuils big boss light communaux
syncrétique album nostalgique will have
des inrocks affaiblissement durable par
la développer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obama
à
bonjour est ce que vous êtes ici pour
les nrj music awards oui oui moi c'est
une question qui m'intéresse pour qui
avez vous voté pour les artiste masculin
francophone de l'année nike soprano ça
m'arrange pas trop est ce que pourrait
dire j'ai voté pour king day
ce qui
c'est pour moi
[Musique]
quand tu es nourri logé blanchi
aucune facture à payer que tu passes ton
temps à dormir et faire des tic toc et
que la seule chose qui te motive c'est
le moment j'ai
m